it's important to be in touch with your
emotions hey anybody out there who says
men aren't allowed to cry you're wrong
i mean that's a it's like a societal
thing where like men are supposed to be
tough and like we're asking oh is that
right you know that i didn't know that
oh do you know that oh yeah thank you
thanks for sharing that welcome you know
what let me tell you something by the
way
my pecs are smaller so it's hard to
tip-flip me anymore no i tried to tickle
you oh he used to [ __ ] when i had
pecs he used to tip flip me like oh i
could still do it don't touch me i don't
watch
you would you remember the words you
used to say
scoop scoop
that's what you do to your friends you
go
well you're not that's here right scoop
yeah scoop like that yeah you don't do
this
no you i did this you did this you did
this
i can't wait to check this tape and
slow-mo it did
listen the guy who was going to help us
with his editing his name is bill bill
check the scoop but also i want you to
slow mo it when you put it on because oh
i was right slow mo it and put it to
some fun music
[Music]
we just go scoop or dip and then we go
up too much bean dip and we slap the top
of the titty back down which is really
funny so you go up and then down and go
up too much bean dip and slap them back
down you'd scoop and then dip yep you'd
scoop slap yeah
scrap
sloop
yeah i like that one ah
skloop
i don't even know it sounds better than
it is yep i don't know i think it sounds
worse than this
[Music]
ah
[Music]